remember last time last week we looked
at similar shapes with of debt areas for
similar shapes we're gonna look at
similar solids now not 2d flat things
but 3d things they've got they've got
some depth to them okay they'll actually
want to take these particular shapes
that you've just worked out surface area
and volume four and what I want you to
imagine is an alternate version of both
of these okay in order for it to be
similar
everything about that cube has to stay
cube cube ish Cubist's cubish okay but
we're gonna change the size okay so it's
five by five by five at the moment let's
make a with my green girl let's make an
alternate version of this cube that's
not five by five by five but let's let's
double all the measurements okay so
let's make it ten by ten by ten we do
that okay now for this new alternate
version to the shape I'd like you to
work out the same two things volume and
surface area all unit surface area if
you were really quick at doing it for
our bigger cube
I'd like you to have a go at this bigger
courage as well do you better and leo
hopefully worked out what the
perpendicular height was is 4
centimeters bless you so I want you to
also work out volume its surface area
for out alternate version of code
witches 22 science so it's not gonna be
5 12 13 it's gonna be 1024 and ok great
so can you work out the volume and
surface area for these similar solids
they've just been doubled in their
dimensions can you go ahead and do that
for me let's think about the
measurements first for the cube which is
the easy bit I think you should have got
a volume of exactly a thousand cubic
centimeters and for the surface area if
I'm looking at things right I think
you've got 600 square centimeters yeah
600 yeah okay now when you have a look
at this I want you to think back to our
work on areas of similar shapes from
last week do you remember if you take
just a flat shape right like say a
square right and if you increase its
dimensions what happens to the area like
if we doubled the size of the length of
a square what happens to do the area the
area is not twice the size what is it
yeah it's quadrupled right because if
you think about your square just picture
picture this square with me right you
double it one way for the width and then
you double it again for the height
because you're doubling it in two
dimensions
so therefore doubling twice is like
quadrupling you're great
what if I am what if I made it three
times become three times because it's
gonna be the area will be nine times
bigger in fact you can draw it like this
this is where drawing just on the side
if you got a minute space if you have
one square like that and you make it
three times wide up and then you make it
three times taller like this these are
the new side lengths right so if you
draw out the whole thing
can you literally see you can fit nine
of the original square in your new
square do you see it see that's why it's
nine times because three that way
through this way okay so now have a look
at your numbers here and what
relationships do you see think about the
surface area compared this surface area
with this one how much bigger is it it's
exactly four times bigger why is that
it's because it's the original surface
area there it is this is worth writing
now next Theo 600 x I'm not gonna write
four I'm gonna write two squared
do you see why it's two squared because
you double it one way and then you
double it another surface area is just
like area okay what happened the volume
it's a thousand now how much bigger is
it
like uh you can put four if you like
obviously to squid and for the same
value but I'm trying to highlight that
you're doing it and you'll see why when
I do this you're doing doubling and
you're doing it twice okay which is
slightly okay
this time it's eight right you started
with nine hundred twenty-five hundred
twenty five cubic centimeters but again
instead of writing eight you're doubling
but how many times you EE you're
doubling three times because it's a
three dimensional quantity does that
make sense so you double and then you
double and then you double again and two
cubed is 8 so made sense if I had triple
things instead we already know that the
area would be nine times bigger what
about the volume how much bigger would
the volume become if I tripled all the
dimensions I should have I should have
said it in a shorter way if I took out
QQ right and instead of doubling the
nation's I tripled them okay so I
tripled them although 15 15 15 the new
volume is going to be 3 times 3 times 3
27 times bigger than people view that
you started with which is very large
right okay come over to the cone now
just want to point out something I've
put on the board which maybe you didn't
notice I sort of ninja it on there while
you were working on things I've actually
taken the approximate answers pretty
much everyone answered to me an
approximate time and I've just added on
the exact answers here okay I've left it
in terms of pi cuz you don't buy it's
got all those irritating decimal places
in that kind of thing so I just left it
there because now I could say hey that's
exact
like it's not approximately 90 pi that's
exactly 90 PI as opposed to this which
is an approximation okay if I do that
and you go to your new working for your
big cone I think what you should find is
where's my surface area here it is I'm
pretty sure you get 360 PI square
centimeters pretty sure you can multiply
360 by PI in order
you've got it's gonna be a thousand in
something right like a little a thousand
this what is it yeah it's the same
number right and the same way when I go
to volume I'm expecting it to be 800 800
PI cubic centimeters you can get check
800 tons of Pi that's 2400 ish epidural
right um
wait and I get those numbers wrong how
did I just think them up without a
calculator in my hands do look back at
your original numbers yeah he's the
brilliant thing about I could have done
it by rounding but I didn't need to
because I've seen a pattern here right
and I can go ahead and I can crunch
through the formulas but this is 90 and
because it's an area I doubled it twice
okay this is a volume remember I started
with this guy over here what's a boy so
when I double how many times do I double
one two three times for three dimensions
okay so this guy T PI is what your
original that 282 number that you gave
me that's where it came from
before you press equals on your
calculator and approximate it okay sir
this is why we looked at areas of
similar figures last week it was sort of
to give you up for this if you know the
volume of a shape you can work out the
volumes or surface area for any shape
that's the same kind of thing but bigger
or smaller okay which is what we call
similar all right